[Music]  you get asked a lot about Bill Cosby  yeah and obviously it's this huge topic  and has been for like I think now the  last year and a half yeah yeah we got  asked a lot about Bill I do I do but you  know is that it's the comic thing you  know but it's like this man it's I try  speed up is that the the all the the  schools and then colleges that they're  taking back their fake degrees he got a  lot of degrees I got a lot of degrees  from colleges yeah  honorary their fake degrees their  meaningless what does that do  yeah give me back that thing you didn't  earn yeah give me that thing that means  absolutely nothing  yeah give me that bag we're stripping  that we're taking that away from you it  seems like if they wanted to hurt him  the first thing they should have taken  away was his medicine cabinet  [Applause]  degrees huh  he should just be allowed baby aspirin  and vicks vapor rub that's it just those  two things I'm those two things that's  it  you